the 500 pounds that's um muted to be
offered
to people who test positive for covert
19.
um it does seem a little bit like
bribery
we've been with this pandemic for a year
doesn't indicate that the government's
message simply isn't getting through if
you're having to
to offer 500 pounds to people um no look
i think the the point is we're obviously
in a full lockdown at the moment so
everybody should be staying at home uh
wherever they can unless they have to go
out to work
we do know we've always recognized that
if you ask people to self-isolate
because
through contact racing they've been in
contact with someone who's had the virus
that is a financial challenge for some
that's why we've always had
a 500 payment for those who qualify for
certain benefits
um i'm not going to comment on this
particular paper but we've always kept
it under review
we do need people if they're asked to
self-isolate because they've been
uh contacted through test and trace we
do need them to
self-isolate and obviously we always
review the the reasons why they might
not it's going to cost
2 billion pounds a month well look no
decisions have been made on this but
this is a
a dynamic fast-moving situation with the
pandemic
but we're always keeping multiple
policies
under review we've had a targeted 500
pound payment
already for those who are on benefits to
help them with the cost of staying at
home when they're unable to work
obviously for most people they would
qualify for statutory sick pay and
there are other supports we've had for
businesses as well
no decisions being made on this uh but
we've always kept these things under
review
another proposal being considered is
that police are given access to people's
health data in the fighter against um
covered non-compliance
are you comfortable with that and the
possible infringement on civil liberty
well look um generally with this uh
whole pandemic we've had to take some
quite
you know extraordinary states very
draconian steps that are a big
infringement on people's liberty
asking them to stay at home telling them
they can't meet and can't go out
none of us want these restrictions to
stay in place a moment longer
but we are in a very uh serious position
as your package showed earlier
we are you know we're seeing uh high
infection rates at the moment that's
still continuing with this new
virulent strain of the coronavirus um
sadly we are seeing quite high mortality
at the moment
there is pressure on our nhs and we need
everybody to play their part to abide by
the restrictions that we've got in place
to limit the spread of this virus and
yes that does mean that we have to
intervene sometimes in in quite a
draconian way and issue penalties
and we'd make no apology for doing that
because you can see the impacts
of this virus spreading but why do you
think it is that still
people are flouting the the restrictions
the covered restrictions what what is
not working
well most people are following the
restrictions so if you go to
any supermarket or any outdoor space
you'll find people
wearing masks abiding by this staying
home as much as
they can i think the vast majority of
people do recognize the gravity of the
situation
and are following the restrictions but
there's a small minority who don't and
that's
it was ever thus that's always the
position and you must therefore have
you know the ability to issue penalties
to those who do flood the rules we do
understand that these are
quite draconian steps that we've had to
take they are necessary we wouldn't do
them unless they
were necessary obviously there's some
fatigue with the measures from some
people
uh but we do need them to abide by it
because we can see
the consequences through packages like
you've just shown the pressures on our
nhs
and that fatigue that you describe is
leading to people flouting the rules and
really wanting one simple question
answered is when will the lockdown end
well the lockdown will end once we've
made further progress
on rolling out the vaccines and we're
doing incredibly well better than any
other country in the world
just shy of 5 million people have been
vaccinated as of yesterday
uh we're vaccinating over 200 000 people
every day
and our aim is to vaccinate all of those
vulnerable cohorts the over 70s by the
middle
uh of uh of february and if we can get
to that uh position then by the spring
we can start to turn the corner because
we will have vaccinated
uh all of the vulnerable people that are
most at risk wouldn't it be fair
just to say to people and be honest and
say that you know this might go on for a
much longer
period than first in visit and you know
we're in for the long haul
well i think we have been straight with
people that this will go on for as long
as it needs to
we do have this more uh virulent strain
we don't want to be in log down a moment
longer than necessary obviously it's
incredibly disruptive for people's lives
incredibly disruptive to the economy but
we're not going to
come out of this until it's safe to do
so and that will require us to have made
further progress on the vaccine and to
have got that
infection rate and the overall
prevalence of the virus back down to
much more manageable levels but we know
don't we that that ireland and scotland
have already extended their lockdowns
um will it follow that we will follow
suit because we always seem to be
lagging behind the other
the other nations well look um different
uh parts of the country have got uh
slightly different challenges and
slightly different approaches but we're
all
ultimately in the same boat fighting the
same pandemic
we try to coordinate and work together
as a united kingdom
but i think the important thing is to to
make the right judgment we've been very
clear that we keep this under review
indeed this week
matt hancock has considered whether
there's a case for keeping the lockdown
in
he's decided there is at least another
two weeks is reviewed every couple of
weeks and that's the right way to do
this
given it it's quite a dynamic
fast-moving situation in the briefing
last night uh the question of foreign
holidays was mentioned
a couple of times um lots of people will
be planning now for their summer
holidays
particularly those on lower incomes who
might have to pay for them in
installments
it's going to leave it very late for
them if a decision comes in the summer
months as to whether they can go away
this year
yes and look and i do realize we
absolutely recognize this that people's
lives are on hold in some ways they're
in lockdown
and nobody can quite see where we will
be by the summer
but what they can see is the pace at
which we are rolling out the vaccine
there is light at the end of the tunnel
once we get all of those vulnerable
cohorts uh vaccinated and start to move
down
the age ranges in sort of late spring
early summer
i i think really think it will be
possible to return to
life much closer to normal it won't be
entirely normal initially
but we will be able to come out of the
lockdown and start
start living life again in the way that
we once did
finally there are reports that ministers
are pushing for a full closure of
borders to
to foreign visitors is that something
that you would want to see
well look um we always keep these things
under review and these it's been uh
considered
there is concern at the moment about the
number of um
mutant strains that there are so
different strains of this coronavirus
are cropping up in other countries
concerns that um there's a risk that one
day there will be a strain that might
be able to evade the vaccine that's why
last week the prime minister
toughened up the current restrictions we
require a test before
people travel and then they must
quarantine while they're here
there are now no exemptions from that
policy so we've already toughened it up
we think that's the right approach for
now but obviously
everything's always kept under review
but is it something that you
personally would like to see that all
borders are closed
to foreign visitors well personally i
wouldn't like to see all borders closed
i'd like us to to get past
this uh pandemic and get the vaccine
rolled out and be able to
start opening things again rather than
closing things but we can't rule
anything out but for now the
restrictions we have in place
with that requirement for quarantine and
the requirement for a pre-travel
test we think that is uh sufficient and
the right and appropriate measure for
now
might you be planning a foreign holiday
um not at the moment uh at the moment
i'm
very busy dealing with other things such
as floods and i know
that many people once we get out of this
will want to return to life
as normal and we'll want to go on that
uh much missed holiday that we've
not been able to have for the last 12
months